[Music]
[Music]
i'm quick takes medici and i'm about to
go speak to a comic dealer about nfts
now nfts or non-fungible tokens are a
way of classifying artwork through the
blockchain making it possible to sell it
in a purely digital form the comic book
industry would be an obvious winner in
this one would assume but that's not the
case as marvel and dc have clamped down
on sales of nfts with their characters
[Music]
so the comic book industry is
predominantly made up of marvel and dc
so marvel and dc are the two big players
because they own the majority of the ips
that you'll see on tv so the majority of
artists and creators that become big in
the industry ultimately will have some
dealings with marvel and dc and do they
pay well that's that's very dependent on
the individual
if you're a new starter then marvel and
dc tend to pay at a much lower level
what artists make money from is from
selling the original artwork
[Music]
okay so let's cut to the chase do you
sell nfts currently no
predominantly because of the fact that
marvel and dc do not allow nft sales of
any of their projects from the artists
that draw digitally so that
makes it quite hard to sell nfts i i
don't i'd be interested in if that
stance softens but as it stands at the
moment we we have to wait and sort of
see what marvel and dc tell everybody
why do you think they issued this ban i
mean like if i can sell the physical
original why can't i sell it in a
digital format i think the problem is is
that over the years because a lot of
artists have moved to a digital platform
that ultimately then hurts them in terms
of selling artwork because they don't
have physical artwork to sell but if
that difference can be bridged and they
can effectively sell on and sell nfts
then it will change things dramatically
i think if marvel and dc
soften their attitude towards nfts then
i think the marketplace opens i mean i
mean some of those pieces could be sold
for thousands
as we left the brixton warehouse it
became evident that nfts are a new
frontier
but simply put they are a way for
artists to make more money
what i wanted to do is do a proof of
concept right the only way i could show
to do that was to burn my own artwork
which in its own way was very cathartic
it sold for 180
000. when i saw that when you know i'm
sitting and watching the auction and i
was just like what
and what do you think is the potential
of nfts in the comic industry a new
market like this allows them to not only
create but to tap into other monies and
it also breaks the chains
of
traditional
paychecks
so marvel and dc aren't very happy with
this whole nft situation what's your
take on that there is a supreme court
law out there that that is that has been
passed that an artist can paint or do
one of it can do an original piece
that's theirs that's their
interpretation that's their everything
after speaking to artists and dealers in
the us and the uk i wanted to find out
just how important nfts will be in the
arc of comic history the value that it
can bring to different types of creators
or consumers is pretty profound so the
main reason that art or collectibles
have taken off is because you can pass a
royalty so that every time a piece of
artist's work gets sold in in the future
they receive a cut of that which is
pretty
impactful if you're talking about you
know the the full length career of an
artist despite the size of the nft
market at the moment they will be a
crucial part of the comic book
industry's next evolution and companies
issuing major bans are defining who's
going to reap the financial benefits
when the time comes
any big company that comes in there and
wants to wants to take that in and just
sort of strangle the artist a little bit
i really need to
think about it think about what they're
doing
in august marvel launched into the nft
space via an app called vivi selling
nfts of spider-man for up to 400
so far there has been no mention of the
creators of the nfts or the original
work
marvel says they are looking into the
issue and will be addressing it in the
coming months
[Music]
you